look we've got to support uh ukraine as
much as we can i'm pleased to see the
announcement
uh from germany uh overnight and of
course it's important that there is that
military equipment to fight on the
ground i think all of us have been
hugely emboldened by the bravery of
president zielinski and the ukrainian
people
and very clearly we also have to
increase
our troops on the eastern flank of nato
to support the baltic states
and to hope that vladimir putin steps
back from what he's doing in ukraine but
also of course his threats that he's
made to the baltic states
do you really think that uh there's a
possibility that he might step back
well look uh the sanctions that are
coming into place are very very
important to squeeze his finances and
his ability to wage war
i raised last week
that we should be placing sanctions on
semi conductors that he needs for his
military equipment there's more that i
hope the government will do in the
coming days in that area but importantly
uh he has not met his objectives uh in
the first four days of this conflict
he's not met those objectives because
the ukrainians have taken up arms and we
must support them in that endeavor so i
hope that over the coming days he will
step back and of course it's important
because this is now square to square
with nato that he steps back from any
conflict that goes beyond the borders of
ukraine
do you
put any credit in the approach that's
been made in belarus this morning
well belarus has allowed its country to
be used for the stationing of russian
troops who are attempting to enter the
country uh i'm not sure that they will
be seen as a
fair-handed broker in this regard the
only thing that should happen now
is that the russian army lay down their
troops and exit ukraine
then the talking can resume i've got to
say when you're seeing missiles fired on
civilian housing blocks when you're
seeing children dying in this conflict
it's hard it's hard to see belarus
as an honest broker
okay uh it seems to me that you're one
with government on that your colleague
yvette cooper however has been critical
this morning of the government's
response on to the likely demand for
visas from people
uh in ukraine what precisely would you
like the government to do how should the
visa regime be changed
look the government have got a visa
scheme it's bureaucratic there's a lot
of red tape it's success
insisting that people demonstrate
salaries that they have
family ties to this country people are
fleeing with their children in their
arms why would you ask people how rich
they are to enter our country of course
there are some people who may not have
family ties but want to come into this
country no we should have a scheme and a
process that's similar to the scheme
that we had after the balkans that's as
generous as the schemes that we've had
in the past when we allow people to flee
idiomine from uganda when we allow
people to flee conflict in cyprus when
we allow the vietnamese boat people to
enter our country that's the sort of
generosity that the british people
expect and frankly uh suggesting that
people should use
this scheme that
effectively fruit pickers come to this
country on
is totally totally unacceptable
so you would say that we should
essentially open the doors to people
who are uh coming out of the ukraine or
coming out of uh neighboring states
bearing in mind the uns talked about
five million
potential refugees
we need a safe sanctuary scheme
similar to the one that we had after the
balkans
uh trevor
the vast majority of refugees
will want to settle in hungary in poland
in the baltic states that is the
estimation of the un but there are some
people who will want to make their way
to our country for whatever reason and
of course we should have a simplified
process a simplified scheme as we're
seeing other colleagues doing in the un
not a scheme with lots of bureaucracy
lots of red tape and effectively that
tells people that they should come as
occasional workers and pick our fruit
that is not the generosity you expect of
our country in matters of war and it is
not consistent frankly with what we have
done in the past when people have been
fleeing conflict all right let's talk
about some of the things that labour has
proposed your leader said yesterday that
the uh russian ambassador should be
thrown out of this country
how would that help
he came to parliament a few weeks ago
and we asked him uh what is russia doing
with troops on the border he denied that
russia was building troops has russia
got plans to come into the country he
said no they do not want to invade
ukraine we've had lie after lie and just
as other countries have said look to
their ambassadors leave our country it
is time for him to leave our country
well uh i don't want to
make too big a thing about this but i
think it was the british who coined the
phrase that a diplomat is a man a person
sent abroad to life for his country but
let me just ask you again what how would
that make any difference to the people
of ukraine uh and who would if there was
no russian ambassador who would you pick
up the phone to
to uh pursue the diplomatic channels
that you've been talking about
trevor
uh we are currently in a situation
effectively of war from russia to
ukraine that's what we've got
we are now going to cut russia out of
the financial system
uh
the posture of vladimir putin will be
very
old our relationship sorry with vladimir
putin will be very hard to recover over
the coming the coming weeks because
clearly
um
clearly he is determined if you listen
to him uh to exact a price on the
ukrainian government
and he is threatening in relation to the
west of course given the lies that he
has told consistent with the pariah
state that russia has now become no
country in the un supporting this action
we should say to his russian ambassador
that he should leave the country
okay well i i think the question i'm
really asking is about um
the things where you appear to differ
from the government i'm really trying to
get some idea about the proportionality
of the measures that you are proposing
uh you've issued a press release this
morning in the name of
rachel reeves yourself and um
nicholas simmons smith who i think
actually i think that's actually
not to nicolas simmons smith is it it's
uh another
labour front venture
i just wanted to check the sanctions
letter that myself
there's a sanctions letter that myself
and rachel reeves have issued this
morning uh we are saying that we think
there should be more banks listed uh we
can't understand why it's still the case
that there are major banks that are not
subject to russian banks that are not
subject to sanctions we've raised issues
about the sectors including insurance
should be included it should not be
possible for vladimir putin to
effectively de-risk
his war escapade uh in ukraine we're
concerned about family members of some
of those oligarchs you heard from this
trust her saying that she wants to bring
forward a hundred names where are those
names there are names on the us list
that are not on the uk
list
why aren't we banning the export of
luxury goods so those are the issues
that we're raising this morning and that
we will scrutinize with the government
when they bring forward their further
plans for sanctions in parliament
tomorrow all right sorry i i raised the
issue of the name because um
actually the third person on that is i
think nick thomas simons who's your
trade spokesperson and the first thing
that you have proposed in that letter is
a
ban on the export of luxury goods and
you refer to the list of uh banned
luxury goods that was drawn up in the
syrian conflict um
is it genuinely your contention that if
we deprive mr putin
of jaguar cars wedgwood crockery and
chocolate truffles which are the only
three things on that list which he can
only pretty much get from britain that
that's going to change his mind
trevor with all seriousness we have been
raising consistently
implementing in full the russia report
dealing
that's why you include them on the list
i'm sorry
my question is do you think that will
actually change anybody's mind
it's part of a package of messages that
of course we've been calling for and
that includes the export of luxury goods
alongside all of those banks many of
which aren't mentioned alongside naming
the hundred oligarchs dealing with those
entities dealing with family members all
of it consistent with us cutting russia
out of the financial system and
squeezing putin the people around him
and indeed the ability for him to
finance war squeezing him very hard
indeed
shadow foreign secretary thank you very
much